[Music]
yes she did yes she did
that's crazy that's Kelsea Ballerini
freaking out over this message from
Shania Twain I love cows Ballerini she's
humble she's talented she writes so I
admire that you know I admire her
humility and grace there's so many
artists right now that I love Petey was
with both music superstars in Nashville
as the Country Music Hall of Fame and
Museum debuted at Shania's new rock this
country exhibit when I say the name
Shania Twain what do you think I mean I
really think that she is such a
trailblazer for not even just women but
just like for country music what she did
and when she did it was so crucial to
where we are now and she's on my shirt
right now also because I'm the biggest
fan girl you love her me
I love Shania Twain and I I really I
mean I think she's just such an icon
when did you start loving her when like
as soon as I could listen to music for
real and you know it's funny I grew up
like I really got introduced to country
music when I was 12 but I listened to
Shania even before that I remember I had
like a karaoke thing that I would like
putting my computer and you could like
do karaoke songs and I just didn't mail
I feel like a woman over and over and
over again like that was my karaoke song
man I feel a woman how has she
influenced you and and just I don't know
if it's musically just looking to how
she did her career how has she employed
hey she's one of those artists that it
wasn't just her music but it was her
style it was the way that she performed
it was so progressive and so different
and I what I love most about her is I
feel like she never tried to be
different she was just herself and like
that's what made it so cool and and had
an edge and in a quirk and I don't know
that that's why I think she's such a
superstar cashews that's what she just
said about you know it's not I mean I
don't even know it's I mean honestly I
look to her and I'm like man
everything you did down to to every
lyric down to every like cool dance
breakdown that you had in a song like
shimmy shake maybe make the earthquake
are you kidding me like that's amazing
just the fact that she did all that I
think at that time was just I mean she's
incredible I got to see her at her Vegas
residency a couple years ago and I just
remember I'd never seen her in concert
before and she came out in a skin-tight
sparkly bodysuit on a flying motorcycle
and I was just like yes ma'am I mean
like how much cooler can you get 15
years has gone by since we've had a
Shania record now we're getting the new
we I didn't realize had been met with 15
years yeah wow this is exciting
[Music]
you